We have a saying in asgard where there are
wolf's ears wolves teeth and ear it's a trap
He's lying just playing games at me
for a sec loki my ears are sharp too
here's the deal fugitive variant's been killing
our minutemen we haven't been able to find them
so let's bring in an expert that's me
the criminal could be anywhere anytime
You got to be careful anything we do can
impact the course of history you get that okay
The timekeepers are monitoring every aspect of
this case trusting this man is not a good idea
no one bad is ever truly bad and no one good
is ever truly good this isn't about you right
Loki Wait
I believe stupidly you can be whatever
you want to be even someone good by the
way i should have an equal amount of security
this is insulting you just can't help yourself
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my loki
episode 5 trailer video loki into the loki verse
there's a whole bunch of easter eggs and a bunch
of footage from the next couple of episodes really
like the final two episodes because there's
only six episodes total so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos because after loki
we're actually gonna be getting the marvel what if
episodes and that'll start in august so we won't
have to wait too long to get the next big marvel
series on disney plus we'll get a couple trailers
for that really soon but we're also doing a
big disney plus giveaway for memberships as
part of that all you have to do to enter just be a
subscriber and post all your theories about what's
really going on here with the timekeepers the tva
a really quick spoiler warning if you haven't seen
any of the loki episodes yet obviously we have
to talk about all the big twists so far but the
beginning of loki episode 5 obviously just picking
up immediately in the events after this loki
in the episode four post credit scene wakes up
on this trash planet amidst all these other loki
variants they may or may not be inside a pocket
dimension but this reveals that the people that
the tva were getting rid of seemingly with their
wands the time reset devices deleting them from
the timeline weren't actually getting deleted
they were just getting sent to this trash planet
whereas before we assume based on miss minute's
explanation the events of episode 1 they were
all being erased completely from the timeline loki
even joked in episode 2 that it looked like they
were actually melting people and things with those
time reset devices which itself was meant to be a
funny reference to the thor ragnarok joke of thor
having to watch the grandmaster's henchmen get
melted grotesquely this whole twist with the trash
planet also kind of explains the big twist of the
multiverse like the multiverse existed before the
loki series but the way they explain things with
lucky episode one created so much confusion in the
fandom there were so many questions about wait a
minute if there's only one sacred timeline how do
you explain the other worlds of the multiverse my
explanation then i think is still valid now
so the idea is that you have this giant river
of time like a greater timeline to describe a
multiverse as it exists right now where in all
these different universes different versions
of earth however you want to think about it
you have people doing things that are just
a little bit different but the things that
they do that are different aren't so big that
they create big branching timelines it's only
when people like sylvie people who are really
different or create events with infinity stones
that are very different very powerful events that
those lead to the creation of another branching
timeline that becomes a fully alternate reality it
at least per miss minutes explanation in episode 1
those are the people that the tva goes after to
quote unquote delete although now we're finding
out that they're not deleting anything so like
i said in my last big post credit scene video
it's kind of like a minority report situation like
them going after people who might cause problems
to the sacred timeline like you know you might
create an event in the future that could create
a branching timeline so we're to get rid of you
before you actually commit that crime but it
sounds like at the beginning of the episode our
loki gets the big info dump explainer from these
other variant loki's the kid loki classic loki
richard e grant boastful loki even alligator loki.
I love that people are wondering if the richard e
grant voice like his voice is actually coming from
alligator loki not from classic loki like what if
the alligator is the one that's speaking but while
they're giving him that info dump like this is why
you need to come with us or you will die this is
what's going on with this trash planet at the same
time back in the tva in the timekeepers room here
renslayer will probably be spilling the beans
to sylvie about what's really going on with the
timekeeper robots and how she's connected to
this massive pyramid scheme apparently i think
it's still important to remember loki's quote
from the trailer at the beginning of the video
no one is ever truly bad or truly good they
kind of foreshadowed the whole dark knight s
twist of the tva when mobius was talking about
jet skis back in episode two everything good
eventually gets ruined so i think it's pretty
clear that when the tva was created initially
it was with good intentions and there was a need
for it at that time but over time they went full
hydra algorithm and started getting rid of people
minority report style anyone who might become a
threat at some point in the future no matter
how minor was treated as if they had already
committed a crime against the sacred timeline and
also over time their dogma about the sacredness
the religious way that they treat the timeline
got worse and worse and worse and all the lies
about the time keepers grew deeper and deeper
and deeper there's a ton of other brand new
footage too confirming our theories about
mobius pretty much everybody had the theory
especially after what happened to loki that
mobius didn't actually get deleted he just merely
got teleported somewhere else we see a version of
mobius that looks exactly like he did when he was
being deleted quote-unquote hit with those wands
but he's driving an old gas car swerving around
a version of the great sphinx of egypt but like
a lot of things on this trash planet the sphynx
is sitting in the middle of a grassy field like
it's not really supposed to be here but somehow
wound up here i think the whole scene with the
uss eldridge explains how all the buildings and
structures wind up here from other timelines like
the wrecked avengers tower in the background too
you see a version of the uss eldritch getting
portaled in or seeming like it gets portaled in
and dropped right on the ground the cool side note
here too when you see the uss eldritch winding
up here it seems a little bit like the portal
effect when you see other ships in the mcu in
space travel through those wormholes like during
guardians of the galaxy 2 when they travel to ego
the living planet they open those jump gates you
see them open to jump gate it's like a hexagon
looking shape and it's them opening a series
of wormholes through different sectors of the
universe allowing them to travel what seems like
faster than light but really it's using wormholes
so because the visual effect is very similar
that might be how the wands were kind of like the
bifrost opening wormholes and if it wasn't clear
that is what the bifrost does it opens a wormhole
but the whole joke of the uss eldritch implies
that the tva hunters are on a mission during the
events of the real world philadelphia experiment
and they're the cause of the ship disappearing if
you're not familiar with the uss eldritch in real
life it's part of the famous u.s navy philadelphia
experiment there was even a sci-fi movie series
that they created based on those events america's
military was trying to create a real-life
cloaking device that would work kind of like star
trek klingons cloaking devices rendering it fully
invisible to the human eye for a short period the
myth is that the ship disappeared briefly amidst
some mysterious green fog they did a couple tests
but then reappeared but the urban legends and the
tales about it go on to say that sailors got fused
to the bulkhead some of them went mad so as you
would expect a lot of those events got turned into
big sci-fi movies later reports in real life
tried to debunk a lot of those claims though
but this is the loki series just playing on that
joke that the stealth technology didn't actually
work it was the tva who was responsible for the
eldritch disappearing then in another scene you
see them confronting president loki i love his
reaction too like come on what did you expect
like he's talking to r loki who's like what is
going on here and i love the idea that president
loki is still trying to get these other henchmen
here to vote him into office like vote president
loki of the trash planet even though we're living
in the apocalypse he's still trying to rule over
everything that's left in the apocalypse on this
battle world scenario here and yes there's been a
lot of people that are making references to secret
wars in battle world because that was an amalgam
planet made up of all the bits of the surviving
universes and that's kind of what's happening here
like you have the bits that survive the deletion
of a lot of other timelines so it's an amalgam
planet then we see sylvie on that planet with loki
together so at some point she either has someone
send her here with the wands or a time reset
device or she just uses one of the tva 10 pads
there's another scene of loki with his dagger on
fire flaming dagger loki challenging something up
in the sky not clear what that's going to be but
it's some big fight that he's getting ready for
then there's a scene of king loki on a version of
asgard in our next big celebrity cameo i believe
this person right here on the right is walt
simonson who was already canonized in the mcu as
an asgardian i believe he had a cameo during the
first thor movie during a dinner scene but this
is sort of like a stan lee cameo style scene if
you're not a big comic book reader walt simonsen
is just one of the biggest classic thor comic book
writers marvel next to stan lee and jack kirby so
he wrote a lot of the stories that are the basis
for the stories that marvel adapts for the movies
in thor but for the most part next to stan lee's
actual cameo scenes walt simonsen is like the next
level stanley cameo we did have jamie alexander's
cameo seen as sift during episode four but this is
just the first time in the loki series that
we have a comic creator doing a cameo scene
like stan lee then there's all the footage in
the scenes of loki approaching a really dark
black looking citadel which might be on the trash
planet or it could be somewhere else i think the
implication here though is that it will lead them
to whoever is really behind all this nonsense with
the time keepers in the tva and i still love
the dueling theories that somehow yet another
more evil more mischievous version of loki is
behind this agatha harkness style it was loki
all along i also feel like whoever is behind this
miss minutes is also connected to it in a deep way
too like she is somehow the algorithm the software
that runs everything that the tva does but someone
would have had to create her originally so there
is probably somebody some person behind all of
this that we'll find out about sylvie also seems
like she has some huge fight scene in this great
room here in this big black citadel so i think
the idea here is that we're going to get our next
big wizard of oz style reveal but when loki said
that he was going to burn this whole place to the
ground in episode one i think they will pay that
off but let me know in the comments whether you
think that that's going to be literally burning it
down like he's actually going to physically burn
it down or just metaphorically burn it down if
they do burn the tva to the ground and they were
the ones that were policing the timeline doesn't
that then create a huge opportunity for people
like king the conqueror to exploit the timeline
to their benefit everyone post all your theories
in the comments below my full loki episode 5 video
will post next week and then we're probably gonna
get a new marvel what if trailer really soon i
did just do a first look breakdown of all the
brand new spider-man suits that they just revealed
he's going to have three new suits so i'll put a
link for that in the description there's also a
rumor that we're going to get a brand new venom
2 trailer next week too so whenever that does
come or if it comes of course i'll do a video
for it everyone click here for my full loki
episode 4 video and click here for my loki post
credit scene video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!